will you play behind the scenes with me
sure it's behind the
[Applause]
scenes I want to go to Postcards From
The Edge um because it's one of my
favorite scenes from you it's one of my
favorite movies and I just love this so
much what was it like to work with
Merill Street uh so you know I mean I
met Merl but it was like hello hi nice
to meet you and then so we're doing the
scene and and I'm very nervous cuz it's
Merill Street and um we did it you know
we practiced it rehearsed and then after
we were rehearsing I heard cut now that
means it's not a rehearsal that means
they're shooting film and in those days
of course I didn't understand how
valuable that was and what I learned was
no no no maybe some better things happen
because you actually aren't worried that
it's the thing that's going to be on
film
and and watching her was great because
what I noticed with her is she never did
it the same way because that's what
talent is she wasn't locked into doing
it a way which is of course the whole
deal have you seen I didn't know that
now do you see her anytime recently like
do you ever run into her I so we were
both at the Golden Globes and she came
up to me and told me she liked
niyad
and I was like wow it's never a bad
moment when Merl stre comes up and says
good job and that is literally my point
that is the way that niad will affect
you when you see it um okay last but
certainly not uh least um where you met
your extraordinary husband
Bugsy
um so my husband and I uh are about to
celebrate 32 years of
marriage pretty
good um and yeah so he was making this
movie so they hired me to play the woman
in the movie and yeah we fell in love so
um was it Love at First Sight um well he
says it was love at first sight
but I think well you know um so for me
you know I have to be honest so I was
going to meet him and um so he's uh he
was incredibly
intelligent that's my that was honestly
my the most um the the biggest
aphrodesiac funny and super smart that's
it that's the two now he's also very
handsome yeah yeah that doesn't hurt it
didn't hurt he's not woring batty for
nothing yeah but um I I thought wow this
is a this is quite a guy but so but I
did I really thought about it
professionally to be honest I really did
when I first met him I didn't think that
there would ever be like a thing between
us it's a it's you know it's the
greatest um I think marriage is like the
greatest thing and the greatest
challenge to to really make it all work
and to make and to stay together and
that is the thing that I am so so proud
of with us I mean it's just you're the
most impressive person
uh both personally and professionally
and to hear from you and to watch
especially in niad like the
demonstration of how we persevere in
this world and in this life and the
water isn't new to you you were on a
boat when you were younger and somehow
you landed a job as a cook on a boat yes
so I was a scuba diver in San Diego um
and in order to get your certification
you have to do a beach dive but then you
also have to do a boat dive and we did
that and then I realized they needed a
cook I didn't know enough to know that I
couldn't do that and then I was I was
not very good just I'm just so you know
I made like grilled shees sandwiches
hamburgers so but it I did it for a year